the latest on Demi Lovato and her
condition and how X Wilmer Valderrama is
taking the news plus what we know about
Demi's former sober coach Oh guys this
Demi Lovato stuff has been weighing so
heavy on me as I know it has for a lot
of youl abadox out there sources told
ichi the singer suffered from a drug
overdose and thankfully Demi's rep told
ichi on tuesday she is now awake and
with her family now according to our
source on Wednesday the overdose was a
wake-up call for Demi and her family now
wants her to go straight to rehab quote
Demi lost control
she's telling her friends and family she
will do everything it takes to get back
to the amazing place she was in before
she slipped the LAPD tells et that drug
paraphernalia was found at Debbie's home
but it remains unclear who it belonged
to and what type of drug or drugs
Demi may have been doing before she
overdosed meanwhile Demi's concert
tomorrow night in Atlantic City has been
canceled and last night Fox porn episode
of beach Suzanne that featured Demi
which was taped back in December but
joining me now is our very own Katie
cross who has actually interviewed Demi
many times about her struggles with
sobriety over the years and you know
what I think that that's what makes this
so incredibly heartbreaking is that she
was always so candid and so open about
her sobriety struggles over the years
and she really wanted to be that beacon
of hope to her fans and to show you can
beat this and if I know anything
Demi is so strong she's such a warrior
and I want you guys to take a look at
this interview it's from 2015 and what
she had to say been very vocal about
your recovery what motivates you to stay
healthy and to stay on this
inspirational path I think what inspires
me is remembering that I deserve to be
the best there I can be and also knowing
that people look at me as a role model
it gives me the the fire to and the fuel
to continue to be strong and try to show
people that hey there's so much more to
life when you take care of yourself and
when you're able to to be the best that
you can be
chill watch right meet you okay look at
all the hairs on my arm my heart just
goes out to her and her family
absolutely and you're not the only one
you know Demi celeb friends and loved
ones have been showering her with love
and I'm not surprised by that outpouring
I mean that's all that you can do is
support and show love Nick Jonas saw
that he was reeling over the news and
her ex Joe Jonas wrote the hashtag pray
for Demi over on Twitter you know I have
to say after we learned about Demi's
overdose yesterday the first person I
thought of was her ex Wilmer Valderrama
because I know that you know they stayed
good friends right and we dated for so
many years and it's clear that they had
that bond a source tells ET that of
course he is shattered understandably by
dummies overdose and while she was
upfront with him when she relapsed he
did not anticipate this last night I was
also a DJ Khaled and Meghan Trainor both
of them have performed with her dj
khaled opened for her on tour yeah
earlier this year so we were with them
at last night's season two finale taping
of the floor and what you guys to take a
look at this so that you actually
tweeted we love you what's going through
your mind about that I didn't know it
was that bad and you kind of feel like
oh my god I wish I was there for her
more I wish I knew her team better and
could reach out right away or but I just
didn't know what to say so I just said
we love you and cuz it's just it's
heartbreaking for her but also her whole
team and her family and everyone around
her it just must be such a shock for
them and what they're going through so I
just hope they're all okay and I hope
she's okay right now in the hospital I
got so lucky I got to sing with her
other Grammys and so we like made a
crazy connection there and but she was
sober back then and just happy I didn't
know it happened like this I know that
you toured also with Demi Lovato's have
you reached out I reached out to her
management I want her to know thank you
so much for being you because I seen all
the great things she's done when I was
on tour with her talking to kids and
telling her stories to her music and
personally backstage she would talk to
him backstage right and I went to one of
our sessions and it really touched me
really got to know her and I told her I
said man sometimes people who got to go
through certain store
so they could tell other people not to
go through him and but we want you to
overcome the storm and never go back to
them storms and I'm praying for I know
she's gonna be great because God is
great and I want her fans and everybody
that knows her bringing that positive
love energy silicon reach to her because
I know how much love can make you feel
good and let's overcome this and let's
keep winning but right now it's about
you getting some rest taking care
yourself and we love you and I know
you're gonna be I preach power ah I love
DJ Khaled and I love how positive he is
about this and it's not wrong either
he's not wrong if anyone can overcome
this it is Demi there's so many people
rallying behind her we all yeah let's
just continue sending her love and
supporting her amen to that well thank
you Katie yeah as you guys know Demi
addressed rumors of a relapse head-on
when she dropped the song sober last
month but we learned that Demi actually
hadn't been sober for months a source
tells us that people close to Demi
starter notice a shift in her
personality and could tell she wasn't
behaving like the sober Demi they've
known for six years our source says
quote the more Demi was overworked the
more she wants to escape and do the
drugs and not stay sober
we're told Demi's downward spiral
started sometime between April and May
when she was on a break from tour it's
during this time our source says she
pushed away everyone that tried to call
her out or help her including her sober
coaches now a little more on that in
July Demi tweeted good luck with your
blog which many diehard fans believed
was shade towards the seniors live coach
mike beier the two unfollowed each other
on Twitter shortly after and of course
mike has been credited with helping Demi
get sober after she went to rehab in
2011 I think a lot of people
don't have the courage to be honest and
speak about their issues and she's done
in such an authentic way that it's
helped millions of people as for what's
next our source says Demi needs a clean
safe place to heal and that is the top
priority well of course keep you guys
updated on the latest developments over
at ET online.com that's it for now but
take care of yourselves
I'll see you guys